and joining me now is the armed forces
minister james heapey good morning to
you from uh kiev and it seems
that the ukrainians are still holding
out still defending this city against
putin's
military they are putting up quite a
fight
they certainly are in fact we in the mod
don't recognize um dominic's report that
melato poll has fallen to the russians
um as far as we're concerned all of
russia's main day one objectives of
kharkiv kersen chenehiv moropol sumi and
melitopol are still in ukrainian hands
and what you're seeing in kiev at the
moment
are very isolated pockets of russian
special forces and paratroopers the main
armored columns approaching kieva still
some way off and that is a testament to
the incredible resistance that the
ukrainian armed forces have put up over
the last 48 hours or so
yeah i mean that would seem to be right
as regards kiev certainly the fighting
we're hearing is on the outskirts of the
city some small arms fighting uh more
centrally but um the fear has to be
uh given it is this massive russian army
that a much bigger more dangerous
assault on this city is about to occur
in the coming hours and days
well i think that's right um clearly the
russian
plan is to take keefe
but the reality is is that the
ukrainians are
thwarting them thus far and that is an
incredible effort on their part and that
brings into play all sorts of challenges
for russia uh they will need
to
start to consider how they will resupply
the troops that have taken longer to get
down to kiev than they thought they will
need to resupply those who have been
engaged in very fierce combat uh all
around other ukrainian cities so there's
a
there's a there's a challenge for the
kremlin that i'm not sure that we think
they necessarily thought they would have
to
uh work their way through
and that is potentially an opportunity
for the ukrainians to um
to fight back even more we'll see what
what what happens look it's a very grave
situation but um from our perspective
here in the md from what we're picking
up from the ukrainians from what we're
seeing um through the various uh ways
that we see things uh it looks like uh
the russian plan is nowhere near running
to schedule
and i think that will be a great cause
for concern for president putin and uh
rather points to the fact that there was
an awful lot of hubris in the russian
plan and that he may well be awfully
advised
well i mean the bottom line is he has a
very powerful military and he could turn
the awesome power of that military on
this city uh anytime he wants i mean are
you still trying to get arms in
to
um to help the ukrainian forces
we are very much trying to get lethal
aid to the ukrainians uh the uk
convened a donor conference yesterday
evening chaired by ben wallace the
secretary of state 25 countries attended
many of whom as a consequence of that
committed to
either humanitarian or lethal aid
which the uk will now work with allies
to make sure is delivered
whereas a few weeks ago we were able to
be
quite open about the fact that we were
delivering n-law and uh we were able to
facilitate media coverage of its arrival
as you will appreciate mark the
situation is now somewhat different and
so the detail of what we're giving and
when is probably something that we need
to keep to ourselves
but ukrainian calls have been heard
we've seen as you will have seen
uh how much the ukrainian armed forces
have valued using the n law uh anti-tank
weapon that we provide last time around
and there's anecdotal evidence that that
has been very successful in battle um so
we know what the ukrainians want uh
we're doing our best to get it to them
but i'm afraid it's probably not detail
that we can share
in with any sort of candor i'm afraid
i suffice to say though are you
confident that you can get this
equipment in
yes
if the russians do come in and topple
this government a freely elected
democratic government
what would the west
do to reverse that
well i think that that is the
the sort of two parts the challenge our
previous conversation about is what he
do immediately to try to assist in the
uh in the ukrainian attempts to repel
the russian advance
and as we've been very clear throughout
that isn't uh i think about nato troops
playing an active role in the conflict
but is very much about looking at how we
support uh the ukrainian armed forces
the why the the longer term competition
with russia sorry to interrupt sorry
sorry to intuitive this is a situation
in which
you know russia is controlling this
country so if you're still going to
support the ukrainian armed forces are
you saying that you would support and
recognize a government in exile
and you would support and arm
a resistance movement wherever that was
being located and based
well that is a decision for the national
security council to
take but it is something that the prime
minister has asked us in the ministry of
defense to look at and plan for so that
the national security council has that
choice to make if and when that time
comes but i was going to go on to to
reflect that actually putin has a
further aim beyond territorial gain in
ukraine which is around fracturing the
nato alliance and pushing nato away from
russia's borders
there's obviously things that the
secretary general has announced over the
last 24 hours to make sure that putin
gets the opposite to what he wants
but then there is a
10 20-year projects i think
where the west will be back into quite
acute competition with russia where
imposing cost on putin the kleptocrats
that surround him so that he fails and
he is seen to fail and he has no
opportunity to anoint his successor and
russia fundamentally changes as a
country as a consequence because the
russian people just have had enough of
him
that is something where i think the uk
and our allies have got
time to make good strategic decisions
rather than necessarily needing to kind
of rush there's the urgency of
supporting the ukrainians in what
they're doing right now and then there's
making good strategic decisions around
how we make sure that putin really does
fail as a consequence of the hubris he's
shown over the last week or two but just
okay but just finally it is highly
likely it sounds or is what you're
saying that you would recognize a
government in exile and help arm a
resistance
uh military a resistance army
no you're you're putting words in my
mouth and i need to be very clear as a
ministry of defense
minister miami a decision for the
security national security exactly
exactly so as a ministry of defense
minister i am
telling you that the prime minister has
asked to be able to have that choice at
his disposal and that is work that the
ministry of defense is uh undertaking to
look at how we would do that
but it is definitely not for me to give
you any level of probability that is a
decision rightly that sits with the
prime minister and the national security
council